so will you play my favorite game with
me yes we're playing behind the scenes
okay
40 year old version what what's the
inside think everyone would be riffing
and seth would be super hilarious and
romney malcolm and paul rudd and jane
lynch and everyone's like really funny
and the crew looked at us like we were
crazy
like they didn't get what the style was
and so the set was really quiet it
wasn't one of those sets where like the
crew's like you are nailing it they i
think it was like clint eastwood's crew
and they were all used to doing like one
tape
right so clint does one take he's like
that's good enough and we would do like
20 takes and improvise for hours and it
was all madness and they would just look
at us like this is not how you do it all
right i just watched it again for the uh
78th time knocked up
[Applause]
movie
yes
tell me something about it about knocked
up well i mean part of it was uh
you know
when we
uh we're about to have a baby
uh we were really looking for a doctor
who would guarantee that he would be
there because you know sometimes the
doctor's like and if i'm busy you know
chuck will show up you know and we were
like we don't want chuck we don't know
chuck we like to just have you do it so
can you promise that you're in town this
month or so and you'll show up and and
uh the doctor's like definitely i would
definitely be there and then leslie's
water broke and we went to the
doctor's office and the doctor said no
that's not
your water breaking and then three hours
later
she's in full labor
and then we call the office and go okay
it's time and they went oh the doctor
just went to san francisco to go to a
bar mitzvah
so i think he lied and said her water
didn't break and we didn't have another
doctor so then we had to call a doctor
that we didn't like that we met to just
pick a doctor and we called the one that
we had rejected and he showed up like oh
now you want
me and that's who dr ken jong was
playing in the movie you know the angry
doctor who showed up after being
rejected and as it was happening it was
such a nightmare i just thought one day
i just have to put this in the movie
because it's so terrible
and then
it all worked out i'm so glad you did i
am so glad you did
okay
talk to me about
sort of like you know
gen z's sex in the city the
groundbreaking girls the girls uh well
i mean the great thing about working on
girls was lena and just her writing i
knew that she was doing things that no
one had ever done before and i don't
think she gets enough credit for really
changing television yes i mean it was so
honest and so frank and she went so deep
uh and i think
if you look at what tv was before and
after it it had a dramatic effect on
what people thought that they could do
on these shows and also to have you know
a a woman as the writer director show
runner star
there hasn't been a lot of that there's
been a lot more sense and i feel like
she opened that door i totally agree i
totally agree also i'm
so in love with adam driver
and it's like the world's biggest movie
star she discovered him train wreck yes
yes
say that
um
what about trick well i mean train wreck
was amazing because i met amy schumer
and then we had a few conversations
about relationships and i would just say
like well what's going on with your
relationships what's going wrong maybe
you should write about that and then
she sent me like 40 pages two weeks
later and they were incredible and most
people you ask them a question like that
and say write up some pages and they
just never talk to you ever again you
just don't people don't deliver and she
worked so hard and wrote such a great
very honest uh movie and then you know
we got lebron james to do it which was
this hilarious thing huge because i
think she wrote his name into the script
almost as a joke and did you think you
would really get him yeah you don't like
think he's gonna do it and then he just
happened to you know be hysterical and
he worked with bill hader on saturday
night live and then he showed up and we
shot all the stuff in a week and for
that week he just had to hang out with
us all day every day okay the king of
staten island
is
is pete davidson as like adorable and
crush-worthy as like all the women on
the planet feel that he is
well
i like suddenly i'm i i'm getting the
whole time green thing right now i
understand how it happens
right that in that era
he was the pete davidson
adam driver of the era he was a pioneer
he did something before anybody else did
he did almost everything before
everybody else did he did the first like
internet talk show candid camera there
was nothing like that yeah but is pete
davidson like is he just so
delightful and wonderful and i feel like
he's just got everyone on his side well
you know he was really brave to sit down
and write his story i mean it's a
fictional story but it's based on all
the emotions he has about
about losing his father and grief
and that's what i found most impressive
about him because there was never a
moment where he said like let's not talk
about that that's that goes too far
that's too personal he really wanted to
share and
by knowing pete i got to know all the
firefighters and the firefighters who
worked with his father and that was
really the best part of making the movie
was just to be in that community
judd
i just thank you so much for everything
that you put out there
[Music]